dans le sport il ya deux modèles de
l'athlète celui qui naît à l'école
danton golf dans les mains comme tiger
woods ou celui qui naît avec des
souliers de soccer une paire de skis une
raquette en cascade aux mobiles au skate
et un petit kit de karaté comme roger
federer
mais peu importe que votre papa est
choisi pour vous le sport dans lequel
vous allez devenir le meilleur de
l'histoire ou quand vous allez c'est le
choisir vous-même en bâtissant vos
propres expériences devenir expert dans
quoi que ce soit ça prend dix mille
heures c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
mon com gladwell et regardez le c'est
sûr que c'est le coach parle si j'ai
bien compris le livre 9999 heures c'est
pas assez
mais dix mille t groupe est même four
après dix mille heures de natifs
on devrait finir par avoir le dos on
peut comme tiger faire c'est dit miller
dans un sport de 0 à 5 ans sinon on peut
faire comme federer s'est dit mais le
première heure au tennis en ayant fait
plein d'autres activités comme la
prendre dans wings l'ennemi juré de
malcom gladwell david epstein
mais peu importe a un moment faut quand
même choisir son sport sauf si tu es
beau dax
et antoine baudry comme temps redit qu
manifestement a pris la bonne décision
de ne pas jouer pour une équipe évoluant
dans un futur centre industriel de
vaccination d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que tom
brady aurait dû accomplir pour avoir une
plus grande carrière au baseball qu'au
football
il aurait fallu que son minimum babe
ruth met à la page et quand michael
jordan est devenu joueur de baseball des
ligues mineures au milieu de sa carrière
ni espérer quoi qu'on fasse un film sur
cette belle histoire
ça n'empêche pas pleins d'autres
athlètes de se soucier régulièrement le
gros orteil dans d'autre part on est ce
qu'ils sont si toute cette semaine
dernièrement le receveur de passes des
seahawks d'yquem et quant à tenter de se
qualifier pour les 100 m des jeux de
tokyo
il a terminé neuvième en 10 secondes 30
centièmes c'est rapide mais c'est pour
bruny surin rapide pour atteindre les 10
mille heures au 100 m
comme mme bruni il lui reste encore
trois millions 600 mille course afin
donc je pense qu'il vaut continué
d'exceller dans la nfl surtout que lui
au niveau de la forme abdominale yopla
d'avoir un petit relâchement pendu mais
même si on me dit miller dans un sport
ça veut pas dire qu'on va devenir le
meilleur est certain qu'ils ont fini par
échouer sont quand même prêt à
recommencer
l'ex quart arrière devenu joueur de
base-ball team petit bourg se lance dans
une carrière d'ailier rapproché dans la
nfl en espérant qu'ils soient meilleurs
pour attraper que pour lancer des
ballons et après avoir dissout sa
carrière de footballeur dans les soirées
arrosées
johnny menzel ça donne dix ans pour
devenir golfeur professionnel
miller de galles par année ça prend bien
et moi je me donne 10 ans pour devenir
un quart-arrière déchu enfin pour
d'autres sportifs bien connu c'est clair
pour moi qu'au moment de faire leur
choix d'où mettre leurs 10 milliards ils
se sont gourés voici les sports les
sports qu'aurait dû faire des sportifs
célèbres
à la place des sports qui les ont rendus
célèbres tomlinson combattants extrême
de la youssef si neymar plongeurs de
haut vol phil kessel mangeant un
professionnel peut gêner bouchard
joueuse de tennis
merci à tous de nous écouter depuis 10
milliards monsieur d
puis cinq minutes et à la prochaine et
donnez nous des gemmes au moins ce n'est
pas une bonne image m minimes a fait
bouger trop bien je sais mais ça va
comme son prix je comprends c'est
vraiment bien